welcome back i love a great weekend
getaway and the sponsor of this next
segment casablanca resort is a fantastic
one and it's just
90 minutes away in mesquite here to tell
us more about their experience or their
golf experience
is assistant general manager christian
aderson welcome back to the show
thanks for having me on jc so tell
everyone what makes your your courses
your golf courses
so special yeah you know mesquite's
become a great golf destination the casa
blanc is this place today when you come
up there we have six golf courses and
six minutes of the resort
so if you're a golf fan you're not going
to spend your whole day driving around
the golf courses
get to play and then come back and enjoy
the resort and you have some great
packages up there golf packages with the
rooms what are some of the specials you
have going on yeah so all year round are
365 days
of the year we have the 99 package which
is one room night and one round of golf
at the casablanca or palms golf club
but right now summertime you can't beat
it 59
one one night at the casablanca one
round of golf the casablanca or palms
golf
59 dollars do you get a beautiful room
yes sir and you get around the golf
absolutely
you get that you can't beat that it's
only 90 minutes away it's a beautiful
drive to mesquite by the way
but up there a few times over the summer
um best of las vegas
yeah you know this is a culmination of a
lot of a lot of things in our at our
property yes
the spa the steakhouse i've all gotten
awards in years to come now
we're we got the gold award from best
las vegas best destination for the
casablanca resort
very proud of that speaks our
hospitality of our staff and the great
time our guests have when they come and
see us it is well deserved someone's
going up there for the first time what's
the must-try restaurant
catherine's by far it's a top 100 most
romantic restaurant last three years by
open table
and we're very very happy with that
award and it's an old school steakhouse
get to come table side service
and bring your significant other enjoy a
nice romantic dinner yeah the customer
service you guys have up there is is
second to none it's fantastic
and you do have some golf tournaments
coming up i know you wrapped up a big
one
but what are some of the big golf
tournaments that are coming up yeah the
first one coming up is over labor day
weekend it's
an armed forces event that money goes to
disabled and wounded veterans
uh so if you're looking for a
four-person scramble come up to the
palms golf course
september 5th and then in november we
have the nevada open which is a
professional event 150 000
in prize money and then we also have the
casablanca two man which is
uh grab your partner come play three
rounds of golf at three of the best
courses in mesquite
and we have six thousand dollars for
each flight for that tournament
wow there's always something going on
out there that's what i love about you
guys and it's family friendly too is it
not absolutely yeah we we have that we
have a great pool at the casablanca
resort so bring the kids up
cool from the pool got a great little
water slide off the pool that the kids
can enjoy
and uh yeah so come on up enjoy and you
know you won't be disappointed at the
casablanca resort christian thank you so
much for joining us we appreciate it
always love having you on the show it is
a great time up there and mesquite only
only 90 minutes away and thank you again
to casablanca resort for sponsoring this
segment
give them a call at 1-877 getaway or
visit them online at casablanca resort
dot com
for more information on their website
there rocky over to you